Patrick Bet David was interviewing Ronda
santis and I was uh I was really
surprised I'm consistently impressed
with uh Patrick B David's ability to get
some of these personalities on his show
he had um Anthony Weiner now he's got
Rhonda santis you know we've got two
people who do booking for timcast and
these people are Terri ified but I don't
even go I don't even think I go as hard
as Patrick M David does but people
really want to be on his show so we got
we got to we got to learn a lessons from
pbd he knows how to handle this take a
look at this story from Newsweek Ronda
santis addresses rumors that he wears
lifts in his boots okay let me just play
the clip from the show dude H I got to
play it's a minute long here we go I'm
sure your marketing team points out how
they're trying to troll you in the
market place okay I'm sure they're doing
that can you bring this one clip I know
you were on uh uh uh what do you call it
on uh uh uh what was it Bill Maher and
Bill Mah talked about the boots I've
seen you walk with these boots go and
play this clip this on Tik Tok went
viral it doesn't have a million views it
doesn't have you know 10 million views
this thing's got 1.2 million likes and
and some people are
wondering what are they I don't even I
haven't seen that what they're they've
not shown this to you okay what they're
trying to say with this is that in your
boots you have
heels no no no those are just standard
off the rack um licy um how tall are you
how tall are you Governor how tall 5'11
okay why don't you wear tennis shoes and
dress shoes uh I do wear tennis shoes
when I work out yeah okay I got a gift
for you I'd love for you to wear okay I
shop at ferl okay
and I got I don't accept gifts I can't
accept it I toally I'm sorry oh man I
his like immediate reaction 511 I I'm
sorry I think wear high heels and I just
want to shout out I think Ashley stclair
may have just driven the final nail into
the disantis campaign coffin yeah this
he's he's not going to recover from this
and I'm not even I'm not being sarcastic
or hyperbolic at all he is not going to
be the president and this is this is
like his I think the guy name was yeah
the dean moment because I
mean the the honesty is like the the
truth is if you're like below 6 foot
you're not going to be the president
people talk about oh half the presidents
have been you know under 6ot and half of
them were over but how many since the
Advent of Television have been under 6
foot I still think 5'11 is the height
men give when they know they're not six
feet not when you know they're not 6
feet but they can't like officially they
want to pretend they're a little taller
so it's like oh I'm 5'11 like no no no
no they're actually like 5'8 and like no
that's not bad I wish he would just own
it right well no I mean he he he could
own it but he's not
never going to be the president if
you're that if you're not if you're not
tall can you imagine he went from being
the governor that was the face of
Freedom the governor that was basically
next up in line if he would have waited
till 2028 he would have probably been
the Republican nominee and now instead
we're sitting around here talking about
does he wear high heels his best hope is
to like get an Instagram sponsorship
with a heel company this is what happens
I don't know that I believe I don't know
that I believe that he ever would be
able to be the president just because of
his height I I strongly believe that if
you're
not accepting Society no because what no
that doesn't count that doesn't know
that doesn't count stop that doesn't
count for men that is not the truth for
men at all but without Trump and the
race would we even be talking about it
Trump is the one who put his people on
this this is a trump that we you know
nobody cared about these things
necessarily it doesn't it I he would get
on stage and be next to someone taller
and that's all it would take okay
because I don't think that I honestly
don't believe that there is a situation
where people are going to look at like
dudes on stage on behind a Podium and if
one is significantly taller than another
they're not going to vote for the short
guy they're just not going to do it you
know we believe in you guys come on I
pulled up a bunch of photos just looking
at my phone of uh from way before s was
running for president and I just looked
up photos of trump uh Trump with the
santis and he looks like he's probably
5'11 unless fake height no men are 5'11
they're just pretending to be un 510
unless he's been wearing high heels the
whole time which is possible and there
no one noticed until now I I imagine
that he probably did he probably wore
him as soon as he it's probably been for
a while as soon as he started dating
mebe I mean if he's wearing him now it's
something that he's been concerned with
we need to get a picture from when he
got married because he got married in
his dress uniform which might be harder
to hide lifts in and then we can do a
comparison to the objects around them
that's my new theory that that photo is
amazing he's floating into the sky this
is what a lot of people said about this
picture right here here that his
uh like they think he's wearing these
fake shoes otherwise he's got really
long halfway to fibula the one that's
like there's no way any human has this
length of bone except for Ronda Sanz
yeah someone said to sanz's heel lifts
are so high it looks like he's being
photographed mid Rapture I just think if
he had respond Photoshop I don't know I
just wish he had responded to this more
positively embraced it with humor
because it would have been a different I
don't know that it would have changed
his campaign completely but it would
have given him the personality that
right now people critique him for not
having right humorless he's lifeless
that's the problem this was this perfect
moment to do something and I'm just
sadly didn't embrace it right I'm not
trying to make him feel bad about his
height you know I I he can be any height
he wants to be apparently but it doesn't
have to be like this and they made it
this weird sticking point that now
people are always going to try and bring
up I don't I I mean I still strongly
feel like Phil will only have a tall
president I gu if I it's not about it's
not about it's about the way that people
unconsciously react it's it's it's not
something that people are going to be
able to identify on their own they're
going to say they'll just be like I
don't know the other guy just looks more
presidential it'll be he's more
commanding I he's I trust him and it's a
deep part of human all about yeah it is
all about Charisma and when it comes to
men taller men are looked at as an
authority that is just the way people
react that is not anything no one thinks
about it at all it's attractive
privilege is all it's 100% attractive
privilege and that's the way that it
pans out for men with women if you're if
you're if you're a large woman you're
not as attractive as smaller petite
women that's just reality I'm not trying
I think it's even Beyond attractiveness
I think you know some of the stuff that
we look for to to indicate Health
well-being that are deep in our
psychology that you know they're young
and vibrant height is one of them I mean
even babies in you know tiny newborn
babies prefer symmetrical faces there is
something deep in our minds that looks
to seek for indicators of health or
strength or whatever it is uh I just
think you know maybe he could never have
been president but I just think the way
his team handled this was how tall is
the issue demented guy in the office
right now Mr abiden how tall is he he's
six feet wow okay imagine if uh Ron just
said well I can't accept the gift but I
can try him on and then stood up and put
them on you got to get out of the lifts
they're probably tough to get out of
though well then see cuz the the thing
about it is that uh this clip this image
right here man it's like the third time
we've talked about this uh the front of
his foot looks like it's smashed up
against the boot up against the boot
like it's really tight on his foot
there's a a clip from an old late night
show when Jake Gyllenhaal people are
like how tall is he and so he just takes
off his shoes and they measure him on
the set of whatever a generic late night
show it is and he comes up less and six
foot maybe 5'11 maybe 5'10 and he just
sort of nods along and laughs with it
and then it that that question just dies
away no one asks that anymore uh and I
think making this into sort of an
internet meme is way worse terrible it
just makes him look like a joke it makes
him look
insecure outside of this Patrick Bet
David asking him the question was a
tremendous opportunity to end it and he
doesn't have the Charisma to to do that
his his his response is well first of
all the fact that he's never seen it but
that's a lie he's seen it probably cries
himself to sleep watching it but that's
just that's just the thing he he should
have been like oh I've seen this clip
I've seen this clip yeah it's a good one
it's not real but instead he's like what
I've never seen this he's like you've
never seen no then you got a terrible PR
team that's not actually you know I I
wonder if it it's true he really he
really has never seen it which would
make it seem like his PR team is like
he's so insecure about his height we
have to hide it from him that's not
great either he hired the worst possible
people in Communications imaginable who
took the front runner to the bottom yeah
if you're the president if you're
running for the office of President and
you don't think that image is important
you're going to lose period yeah you
have to understand that half the that
most people make their decision about
you with their gut they don't think
about it they're rationalize their their
their emotional reaction after the fact
that's just the way human beings work if
you don't portray yourself in a
charismatic way the reason people love
Trump is because he's charismatic in a
way that's attractive to them and that's
also the thing that some people find
repulsive nobody likes Trump because of
his policies CU Trump doesn't have any
policies the policies are going to
change depending on the last person he
spoke to no one no one hold on hold on
that's true no no no his policiy Chang
depending on what Tucker Carlson said
that night fair enough okay it's
depending on what Tucker car but but to
be fair there's that Tucker Carlson
anchor on on Trump you know what I mean
I mean I think that Tucker Carlson puts
thought into his Pol into the policies
that he would or would not back I don't
think Trump does I think Trump is is
just driven by his gut see but we can
forgive stuff that Trump does because of
his we can't forgive the santis cuz I
mean he's like a lump on a log it's just
it doesn't work and Trump has proven
that he's tall because Baron is like
what 607 ft tall that's the comparison
put the santis next to Baron oh never
the way it's going to be Trump trump
2024 Baron as VP and he's just like 10t
tall at this point everyone's just like
his like knees don't fit under the desk
he's just so enormously tall going to be
the first emperor there's a lost known
uh um uh Statute in the Constitution
that says you have to be at least 35
president or at least 10 at least and
baron is like I'm on my way Bar's
qualified y this is well that's uh
that's your Presidential news outside of
uh uh Donald Trump we just skipped over
Pence dropping out over the weekend and
we're like he boots that's how boring
the puns campaign has been when I we
were hanging out in Pittsburgh and I'm
like I look at my phone it's like Mike
Pence has dropped out and I was like oh
and I hit retweet and I was like what
were we talking about again I what were
we eating I think we had uh what did I
have for for dinner I Thai food I said
it to my more interesting than Pence
yeah I said I told my step I was like oh
Pence dropped out and she's like didn't
he already do that he's running he
dropped out January 6 2021 in to be to
be fair to be fair you know even the
fact that we're making fun of Ronda
sandis is better than Nikki Haley she's
just I don't she's in second place and
is is a lump is a lump on a log she's
loved by a certain crowd though over 60
yearolds they absolutely love this woman
and it's it's this old war mentality
this old America has to be in charged in
the police state you know and all that
stuff well someone's got to blow up
these kids right that's that that's the
ne I want a department of offense not
defense she said that yeah she said I'm
want a department of offense you go
fight a woman I mean that was a joke I
made a long time ago to my friends that
we don't have a Department of Defense we
have a department of offense and all my
anti-war buddies are laughing and now
she's just coming out and saying it so
do she want to go to war with everybody
you name the country I mean fair enough
that war with Italy if she
could but I just I don't see I I mean
currently there's there's the argument
that Iran is is funding Hezbollah and
that it's possible that there' be some
kind of Engagement but that is pretty
far down the road still and I don't
think that it's a direction that we
should be trying to go the the the
American people have no desire to go to
war with Iran at all American people
don't have an appetite for war right now
right now American people don't want to
go to war with for anything no we just
want to fund for can you imagine they
send our people to fight in Ukraine our
soldiers to fight a war in Ukraine well
they've already deployed thousands to
Europe for the war in Ukraine disgusting
and we have special forces there these
are lives of people they don't
understand that part now I guess uh
Ukraine's kind of falling the back
burner Al lensi is the you know he's
yesterday's news back on seeking
Arrangement looking for a new sugar
daddy that's right that's right I think
that the the the war in Ukraine is has
been basically decided you okay down
there no this is so funny it's true
I I mean I don't think that anyone
that's serious believes that Russia is
going to give up any of the territory
that they've taken no and I don't see
any reason why the US should keep giving
money to Ukraine I don't think Russia's
looking to take more territory in
Ukraine either if they if if the
ukrainians and the Russians can say okay
this is it I think that that it could
they could have have some kind of
ceasefire there would have to be there's
going to be new new borders drawn and
that's just the way it's going zsky
doesn't want that he we'd have to stop
paying him so much money well nobody fun
for him the US doesn't want that either
because they'd have to stop laundering
money everybody it's not goingon to laer
itself that's so true everybody's making
a killing on this war and I hate to say
it the best thing that could happen
would be Russia wins and we don't have
to deal with Russia did win because if
if Ukraine rebuilds guess who's
rebuilding everybody in here is tax
dollars Russia Russia won yeah right the
the it's it's fascinating if you look at
the start of the war and the territory
gained by Russia mhm and the argument I
get from uh uh more establishment
conservative types is no no Russia
wanted the whole country like no they
wanted the land bridge to Crimea like
that's what we've been saying non-stop
now they have it and now nothing's
changed there's no advancing it's just
locked and Russia got what they wanted
yeah and we'll never know when it really
ends because the money laundering would
stop so this will go on into the next I
mean well no I think I think it'll
likely end um because Israel's firing up
true that's a good point they got to
figure out just how to launder it right
through there and we'll be good yeah yep
once they get the bank accounts all set
up I don't think we should be sending
any more money to Ukraine when we have
people right here in the United States
that are suffering and cannot afford to
pay their rent and are staying and
sleeping in the streets amen yep that's
a simple as that isn't it sure is but
for some reason you get Mitch McConnell
what what did he say the biggest
priority was funding for UK fing Ukraine
he should go over there he can have his
little strokes in the next to zinski wow
he Lindsey Graham deploy them first I
mean that's the craziest thing at least
Nikki Haley's husband is actively
deployed right now he's in Africa but
you know she therefore is willing to
send her own husband to war it's a bold
choice on my opinion but you know uh all
of the politicians who call for funding
for war want to send your children and
your siblings and your cousins they
don't want to go themselves and they
don't want anyone they actually know or
related to to go I think Lindsay just
likes the war stuff because it makes
them look more masculine and we all know
what's going on there oh I I think these
people are just funded by Massive
multinational corporations in the
industrial complex and so they're going
to go on TV and warmonger thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net